foreign
news briefing it's Thursday June 1st I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
some Facebook content moderators in
Africa are suing the social media Giant
and the contractor that hired them over
worker exploitation and unfair
termination in legal filings workers
claim that reviewing graphic content
including some that contained violence
and sexual assault led to depression
PTSD and anxiety the contractor
california-based Sama denies the
allegations and says it supported
workers Facebook parent meta declined to
comment on the litigation three separate
lawsuits in Kenya are casting a fresh
Spotlight on the tech industry's
far-flung outsourced Workforce to
discuss this is our South africa-based
business reporter Alexandra Wexler Alex
there are three cases here but I want to
start by talking about the one focusing
on the health effects faced by Facebook
content moderators can you tell us a bit
more about what these moderators did and
how they claimed they were impacted by
that experience yes so the content
moderators involved in one of these
lawsuits there are 184 of them and
basically they say that they've suffered
severe psychological trauma in some
cases that's led to physical illness
things from depression to PTSD to
anxiety because of having to look at
this really extreme content including
things like child pornography rape
beheadings
suicides to basically make sure that the
rest of us don't see that kind of
content on Facebook how has the
contractor Sama responded to their
claims so Sama says that their working
environment that they provided for the
content moderators was world class they
had a lot of benefits things like paid
parental leave vacation health care
access to counselors the moderators had
unlimited what they call Wellness breaks
you know if they needed to get up walk
around sort of shake off what they were
looking at and the moderators are saying
that this was not as nice a working
environment as Sama claims that the
counselors were unprofessional including
things like not observing
confidentiality that they weren't
psychiatrists or psychologists you know
weren't trained to deal with this kind
of level of trauma the content that they
were looking at was for Facebook has
Facebook parent meta responded to this
case So Meta has declined to comment on
the ongoing litigation then but they are
arguing in the Kenyan courts that their
Kenyan courts don't have any
jurisdiction because meta says that they
don't have any offices or any employees
in the country directly they've
outsourced all of this work and the
Kenyan courts have preliminarily ruled
that they do have jurisdiction and meta
has appealed that ruling what could the
implications be if meta is included in
this lawsuit a lot of these companies
from meta to tick tock to other social
media Giants Outsource a lot of this
content moderation into different parts
of the world especially because
different parts of the world obviously
speak different languages and so it's
very helpful to have local people who
understand local social context and
local languages moderating that content
so it could open up big tech companies
to a whole host of similar suits in
other countries in theory what about the
implications for Kenya which has tried
to present itself as an Outsourcing hub
for tech companies it could spell
actually quite a bit of trouble for
Kenya because
Kenya is as you said trying to promote
itself as a destination for a lot of
this Tech Outsourcing work so not just
content moderation but work like data
annotation teaching AI systems how to
recognize images recordings so obviously
if Kenya rules that meta is responsible
for the work that its outsourcers are
doing in Kenya that could definitely
have a knock-on effect on companies sort
of shrinking their Workforce in Kenya
what about the other two cases what do
they focus on yes so the first case is
Daniel motong and he was a Content
moderator who a few months after Osama
started doing content moderation work
for Facebook he tried to organize around
150 of the moderators to protest working
conditions as well as ask for better pay
and he claims that he was fired for
attempting to form a Union we should
note that Sama says he was fired for
causes unrelated to his attempts to
unionize and that the company would have
worked with a union had one formed
okay so tell us about the second case so
the second case has been filed against
just meta not Sama in Kenya's high court
that was back in December and that
lawsuit was brought by among other
people the son of an Ethiopian Professor
who was shot and killed in November 2021
after posts about him which were
allegedly untrue went viral on Facebook
and the lawsuit is basically claiming
that the content moderation taking place
in Kenya which is the reason why the
suit has been filed in Kenya wasn't
adequate enough to stop this hate speech
and so that lawsuit is seeking the
creation of a victim's fund for not just
these people who filed the lawsuit but
for anyone who's been affected by
similar situations on Facebook in
sub-Saharan Africa Alex Facebook did say
in a statement that hate speech is not
allowed on its platform and that it
employs staff with local knowledge and
expertise to help find and remove such
content but I'm curious what other big
tech companies you know beyond meta will
be watching for in these cases yeah I
think other big tech companies will be
watching for how the Kenyan courts
handle these cases the kind of liability
that Facebook faces so they can make
decisions about how they're going to
handle content moderation and the
Outsourcing of work like that going
forward all right that was our South
Africa based business reporter Alexandra
Wexler
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]